do you have any questions for me
yeah we got hot on
it's my turn to be a tv host because i'm
actually thinking about doing tv do you
want to take this chair and i'd take
that chair for a second yeah
this is excellent this is great
i think like i actually want to start my
own podcast well first things first stay
in the microphone
you got to talk into a microphone
okay i've never really taken the okay
this is pretty cool all right you got
some things going up up here like
welcome to the micah parsons show you
got to talk in the microphone there you
go welcome to the micah parsons show
where we'll talk about you know let's
talk about life you know sure michael
what's on your mind
rich where'd you come from
i'm from originally from new york city
staten island new york that's right the
uh the east coast that's where i'm from
where are you from harrisburg pa is that
the east is that the east coast close
you right up the road about three hours
three and a half and a half you know
actually
you're a little further i'll say like
four or five okay so you consider
yourself east coast not eastern time
zone yeah high schools here's my problem
is i'm now interviewing you still so my
bad
i'm not control free that's what a good
host is a control freak where you you
can't you know take your hands off the
steering wheel so i'll do that now now
so go ahead
what else
okay
um what college do you go to university
of michigan
and we're off the rails yeah i was about
to kick him off my shoulder
okay so i guess that'll wrap him i was
having this conversation right yeah
because i'm a dreamer okay and i think
we all should have dreams and we should
all chase dreams
and
but i always say you only have one dream
at a time but you reach goals within a
dream because the dream starts at the
beginning
so someone had asked me it was like what
was the most thing you accomplished this
year and i was like okay my accomplished
the most accomplished thing i ever did
was getting drafted it was like really
it was like why and i was like because
that was my dream like i wanted to
always get dressed to nfl like i was
like you don't picture winning defensive
rookie of the year like you don't
picture winning um defensive player of
the year like you like you dream again
drafted making it to the nfl like that's
what it's all about but within that
dream it just expanded and those were
like goals i accomplished so um
what are your dreams my dreams well my
dreams is to get back in that chair um
no but
my my dreams uh is to um hmm
just i don't know i'm kind of living it
every day to be very honest with you so
your dream was to have your own show i
i've always dreamt that i i've dreamt
about talking about sports for a living
and being a dad and i literally live my
dream every day but um if i had any
dreams just do you know keep expanding
this show stay with the
my career as long as possible like
that's the sort of thing i could do
where in l.a do you reside like what i
mean you want me to give my address out
on the yeah
i mean oh
i don't like being in this chair yeah it
is tough this chair is tough so it's
lower than the than the uh than the host
chair
do you like doing this sort of thing you
want to you should do your own podcast
you want to do your impact i'm i'm i'm
building
something okay so far okay okay it's not
something i can do right now because i
got a million things to worry about sure
like like what what are you doing right
now you're just being a dad and you're
getting ready for the season right well
i'm eating pizza
which means he has to work
you tell me that's not spicy
come on now i just had something okay
good
there you
go but should we play what's more likely
with micah parsons let's take should we
take a break come back break come back
we'll play you got one more segment yeah
okay here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna i'm sorry uh i'm in the
guest chair you stay there we're gonna
come back and what
explain to him what what's more like
that all right so uh mike it's very
simple i throw out two topics and i ask
you what's more likely but it's like
first take you gotta split screen and
have it have an opinion
don't dance around
and
we're back to the micah parsons show and
we are going to play
what's more likely yes we are
are we going to wait for them yeah well
we gotta wait for the terrestrial radio
audience is about to by the way good
welcome back right there
for anybody out there on peacock who's
wondering if you just tuned in
what's going on micah parsons just did
to me what he's done to the rest of the
nfl which is unseat the quarterback
that's what he does
that's what he's expert at
and he's got the best dad ever signed in
front of mind
yeah crushed rich and manipulated him to
let me take over this show
yes you did
yes you did
what it what it what no i i screw it i'm
going to ask you another question what
is that what does the your sweatshirt
mean what does that mean
the anti-social social club mm-hmm
it's just a brand i was going i was
going to win something
but i didn't want to fool you okay all
right where's that uh where's that chain
from honors tonight
yeah i didn't want to bring it out
it's kind of like
it's hidden
there's a lion right that was a lion i
saw that lion are you a lion rich
what do you mean how about this what's
more likely you got hopping in a cage
with a lion yes
or
or tyson or
no or jaguar
hmm
does that say something about me either
way that i answer or what yeah it's like
those dumb combine questions no no it's
a legit question i got a legit like
backup answer okay
i'm more likely to drop a hop in with a
lion
okay
yeah yeah
okay
yeah i like that i like yeah yeah
why like why why because i think we're
both uh we have a kindred spirit and i
think i could actually relate and thus
not get eaten
by said lion
yeah
that was a okay like answer
okay okay because you're supposed to man
you chose the right answer you're
supposed to say the line yeah but what
was my supposed to be
but you're supposed to say so you can be
king
oh
not because you could relate or
correlate okay because you got to take
over you're trying to take over the
jungle it's tough sitting in there
you want to be like i always say this in
life you're going to be a part of the
jungle you're going to be on top of the
jungle understood so i'm realizing what
the micah parsons show is you ask the
questions
and then
i have to give the right answer
is that the way it works well more
likely
but you just you you've got 50 of the
question right halfway home yummy
fantastic all right so we're three
seconds away from the terrestrial radio
audience returning
you can welcome us back go ahead micah
parsons and welcome back to the micah
parsons show where we are playing more
likely there's more things you know i i
was only supposed to be here for one
segment i'm giving you guys two because
because you're an overachiever it's just
too important to me for these questions
to go unanswered okay very good so uh
micah parsons sticking around for
another second
i'm in the guest chair
micah you're in the host chair you look
good in the host chair by the way i got
to tell you dude i got a nice glow your
lighting is better too
the lighting over there is amazing yeah
there should be some changes around here
my man can you get a bigger desk
like
i kind of like it back here
tell him why you have the velvet
perfect person for me to explain why
this rope is here right dallas cowboy
fan my whole life as you know people
love to trash talk to cowboys right
it got to a point where because now i'm
on the show and i hold up this sign
every week win lose or draw i got people
coming at me i can't fight everybody
mike i got other things to do so i
devised the tier system right advise a
tier system about who i would argue
football on the screen so if you're a
fan of like chris brockman he's a
patriot fan if he wants to talk trash
open up the rope i love him come in the
club we'll sip on something then we'll
talk football but like caroline and
panthers fans who want to like talk
trash to me they've never been in the
club i mean they never in the super bowl
that means they can't get into the club
i'm not going to waste my time arguing
i had to devise a system but at least
they've been in the super bowl if you've
never been in the super bowl just stay
there both stayed home don't get
showered on friday night that fit you
picked out yeah
you picked out did you look good in
return it get your money back stay home
and peacock and chill yeah
club if you've got no super bowl
appearance i respect that my man i knew
you would i respect that two east coast
kids right micah that is such a
respectable answer too easy altoona and
harrisburg stand up that's what i'm
saying all right all right mike are you
ready yep all right all right hit the
music let's go
what's more likely ladies and gentlemen
well there's there's a dress i know we
have animation that's what i said let's
hit the music hit the music hit them
[Music]
what's more likely never say never but
never there we go that's the open fort
michael all right micah we're gonna
start out with some nba what's more
likely association back last night full
slate tonight
sons what's more likely the suns run
away with it in the west
they're up six right now or the warriors
come back and chase them down and get
the one seed the warriors
why is that
oh man
steph curry's a lion
okay he's
man and now the clay back he's getting
back into his rhythm right now i really
believe in clay i thought he should have
been at nba top 75
that is a yeah he got left out yeah he
should have been here so i don't know i
mean the sun's the sun chris paul is
going to be out two months i know chris
paul's out two months so it's more
likely that the warriors are the one
seed than the sun staying in it that's
what you're saying
i don't know about that and i think the
warriors and i said before the season
that the warriors were going to win it
all yeah i don't know i think six games
is a hell of a lot it's too many to go
so i'll go with the suns for what's more
likely just for just to debate make sure
we save all these so that way
i might come back on the show and write
a couple words
uh micah do you have an nba team do you
have a favorite nba team warriors
okay you're a warriors guy
well tj cowboy fan likes the
philadelphia 76ers james harden makes
his sixers debut tonight in minnesota
what's more likely harden 30 and 10
tonight sixers win or
minnesota gets them philly loses
hard in 30 and 10.
that's my guy right there because
i think harden he's at a prove it stage
right now you know he's been battling
injuries and stuff like that he said he
wanted to be a 76 years so because he
wanted to win a championship well your
debut is the time to show it baby this
is my guy right here man how many times
has hardened my man be in this position
though he's had to prove it in the nets
and he had to prove it for their rockets
he had to prove it everywhere else he
did prove the rockets yeah i think he
did he had no help how many times chris
paul oh my god
only chris paul russell westbrook come
on now oh
hello you see what's going on l.a
yeah we see i don't know i'll take the
timberwolves i'll take the timberwolves
winning tonight all right speaking of
come on
no i'm not gonna do that that's by the
way that which makes for good tv for for
you as a host you you'd probably want
that anyway but how about what karl
anthony towns can't finish up his
three-point
um championship with a w tonight by the
way anthony edwards is one of the best
in the league
d russell russell embiid
let's see how it works let's see how it
works let's see how it
one more works and then we're going to
go to the nfl one more nba game
the lakers
clippers lakers play tonight right who's
more likely to go on a run and get out
of the play-in tournament who's more
likely to get in the top six clippers or
lakers
why
uh
i just believe lebron he's got to make
it this year
just for his legacy
he got to
i'll go with the clippers
i think the clippers are a better team
and i think they're a better coach team
and i like them i like them a lot i like
reggie jackson i like what ty lue's
doing sometimes talent beats culture
can't teach talent
okay
all right let's go to some nfl topics
guys
who's calling games hot topic this week
troy aikman's going to espn fox has a
big hole amazon's trying to fill so
what's more likely tom brady on retires
and plays in 2022 or
he joins fox or amazon in the booth
george fox or amazon
you think so do you think he's done yeah
you really think he's done yeah
done done
done done
inside information you want to build
some no i just feel like
his career is definitely legendary
greatest quarterback of all time but
i mean
it's 40 what 44 46 44 44. yeah i think
at that stage it is time to like you
know really think about being yeah the
best dad ever
yeah you know what i'm going to take him
playing in 2022. yeah rich that's all
i'm going to do because i don't see him
calling games at all he's see look i'm
getting in his am i getting in his grill
right now we're getting his girlfriend
contact i'm noticing his grill so what
does this actually mean to you
the best dad ever that's an important
point so tom brady can't be the best dad
ever no he can be the best dad so why
can't he spend a year being the best dad
ever
he's been he spent
22 years being the best football player
ever let him go be the best dad ever
rich
he's got a point rich you got a point
what's the last one over here last one
all right
i'm not saying john brady hasn't been a
great day that's about safe but he wants
to be the best
here's where we're going to make some
news here's we're going to make some
headlines
what's more like
everything is actually cool with the
cardinals and kyle murray
or he's somewhere else in two years
everything's cool with the cars and
column or
you're saying that just because you
don't want to get in any you don't want
to step into this phrase
defensive rook of the year you don't
want any you want any
when you are hosting your own show you
have to answer questions like this like
that's not our fight and i'm gonna tell
you this okay yeah but it's not he's not
micah parsons
four years ago they dropped to josh yeah
then they drive colin murray at number
one yeah calamari has proven himself to
be
on pro bowl caliber top quarterback in
the nfl
and he's young
there's no way in their right minds that
the cardinals ain't gonna figure out for
him instead
they can't take another quarterback you
can't find another kylie murray nowhere
in the league leak
calamari is not going nowhere they would
never allow that
ever
i agree with mike parsons on that front
that's it you think we need one more oh
no all right we'll get one more okay one
more bonus what's more like that
question too
what's more likely
that you micah parsons
breaks the single season sack record or
cowboys win the super bowl
yeah
cowboy super bowl
let's go
can you dance
mikey
is he looking at me right now is he
looking at me right now
he is scaring
the audacity
that's cool cause they're both more
likely that is the okay the answer is
both is that what you're saying okay it
could be all in one see yeah there's a
option c micah option c yeah
hey
you got one yeah what do you got because
you know
this has been bothering me and i've been
seeing a lot of people talk about who's
the fastest man okay
yeah and i want to answer from you like
who's more likely
me catch the cheetah
or
the cheetah catching me
in what in a foot race
for race football
i'm so
what's more likely that you you can run
down the cheetah
where the cheetah runs away from you
yeah
he's staring right at you
come on micah come on really
really you're faster than tyree kill is
what you're saying to me first of all
yeah
come on
this is this is football this is
football i understand we're talking
about running down so there's angles
there's pursuits okay
okay
i'll take you
i'll take you i'll take you i'll take
you tracking down the cheetah who would
you take
i'm taking me too of course i have a
question
so tell me tell me the cowboys play the
chiefs next year
now we played some of this year oh he
played him this year oh that's right
how about what happened oh rich come on
now oh
did that happen i didn't i didn't you'd
have an opportunity to do it okay that's
right okay do they play next year again
or no they don't play together oh damn
we played new division would you want to
do that if i invited you to do it for uh
for charity if you're here in los
angeles you want to do it i wouldn't
raise him head up again
no no not head up but i might you know
we i could on the route okay he could
cover me
i like it
well like i said he i think this man
believes he can do anything and i'm not
going to tell you
and i want tyrique to cover me do you
want to play offense would you do that
yeah
[Laughter]
have you have you suggested this to mike
mccarthy and what do they say
they obviously
don't see the vision i see it
rich i believe micah could kick field
goals and extra points they just don't
want to put them out there
y'all are making me go on the borderline
of things i can't answer
or don't want to speak about welcome to
the micah
show
you know i think i think it's better
it's the micah parsons project
nice
the micah
micah thank you for coming on i
appreciate that i really appreciate it
uh shout out to peacock yeah without
right you know you're using it are you
signing
micah
yeah um shout out to
rich thank you for allowing me to collab
on this luxurious day
um
always remember guys
stay hungry
and while you're
hungry eat the pizza yeah buddy
courtesy of pizza hut everybody thank
you for uh bringing micah parsons here
thank you micah for coming on the
program
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here